this wasn't really what anyone had in
mind instead of a celebration of Freedom
creativity and self-fulfillment fueled
by plenty of psychedelics the annual
Burning Man festival turned into a
mud-caked drag when that most
unpredictable of partygoers Mother
Nature decided to come and hang out for
the weekend there's hundreds of vehicles
that are completely stuck in the mud
there are people walking on foot to the
nearest city of gerlock
and there are camps a lot of Europe
European camps that fly in and and do
Burning Man have left everything they're
trashed their tents uh their
infrastructure so this is a disaster
like never been seen at Burning Man the
rain started on Friday and quickly
turned the alkaline desert soil into
thick cloying goo Nevada authorities
shut the place down and told revelers to
shelter in place face some tried to hike
or drive out but it wasn't easy someone
Wrong Turn and everyone followed
father with a known
no one slept there people who had formed
various camps provided food and
electricity from generators as well as
limited access to the internet some
Festival goers welcomed the challenge
South Hill in the sunset
on this crazy crazy sunset this is a
burning fun fashion 2023.
[Music]
people
catch the Wi-Fi here
approximately 70 000 people attended the
Annual Festival held hundreds of
kilometers from the nearest town
authorities reported one person died
over the weekend but said his death was
not considered related to the weather
issues
despite the mess some participants say
they'll be back it's still a great event
I love it and I'm definitely going back
next year better luck next time Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera